después de despedir a su gobierno a
principios de este mes y hacer llamado a
un gobierno de unidad nacional el
presidente de sri lanka gotabaya
rajapaksa
juramento un nuevo gabinete que no
incluye miembros de su propia familia
aunque su hermano se mantiene en el
cargo de primer ministro el mandatario
aseguró que buscará solucionar los
problemas incluyendo a través de cambios
constitucionales
existe la oportunidad de discutir en el
parlamento las opiniones expresadas por
varios partidos políticos sobre los
cambios requeridos en la constitución y
aprobar las enmiendas necesarias
desde el domingo los simpatizantes del
opositor partido nacional del poder
popular tester y lanka iniciaron una
marcha de tres días caminan de la ciudad
sureña de bergua la hasta colombo
insisten en que el presidente debe
renunciar y lo acusan de exacerbar la
crisis económica al introducir recortes
de impuestos masivos después de su
elección en 2019 lo que ha resultado en
cortes de energía prolongados escasez de
alimentos combustible y medicamentos una
inflación interanual de 18 7% una fuerte
caída en el valor de la moneda la bolsa
de valores cerrada por cinco días a
partir de este lunes y está en curso un
incumplimiento temporal con el pago de
la deuda externa ha suspendido las
conversaciones con el fondo monetario
buscan alrededor de cuatro mil millones
de dólares que se entregarían con la
condición de que es tri lanka acepte un
estricto programa de estabilización
económica el país también ha estado
buscando la ayuda de india y china los
dos países ya se han comprometido a
brindar un importante apoyo financiero